we're going to think about this tennis
ball for a little while now
unfortunately or maybe fortunately I
couldn't do this demonstration inside
like I did with the wineglass so you do
not have your paper with you so you're
just going to have to think and not do
it with a pen in your hand okay now I'm
going to do a few things with this and I
want you to just like we did with the
wine glass and the water I want you to
observe even obvious things I want you
to tell me about them okay now also like
the water I will try as best as I can
I'm not gonna be on Judas perfectly but
hopefully we ought to do it enough so
that you can draw some conclusions from
it okay for instance I'm gonna throw the
ball at once I'm gonna do it in a very
very simple way it's gonna be very quick
I want you to tell me what you see
anything that you can observe about how
this works so here we go all right ready
okay
what did you say do you need me to do it
again I'll do it again I try and do the
same at all right I already heard one
thing which was it goes up then it comes
down that's pretty obvious isn't it
incredible what else did you see
ah it goes so you talk you're telling me
something about speed right I'll do it
again I'll do it again you can make a
more detailed statement
well that was 200 sorry okay what did
you notice about the speed did it come
down faster
it went up it felt like it didn't write
the speed definitely changed right it
wasn't going the same speed the whole
time when was it going well you said it
came down faster where is it going
slowest at the top how do you judge that
it stops right it stops up there for a
brief
okay alright are there any other obvious
things you can tell me it's okay so you
can tell you have the object I'm
thinking about how it's okay all right
now people with their stop watches here
is where I need you now I'm going to get
you into pairs
actually could you guys pair up so my
eyes are watering because I'm looking
directly into the Sun pair up people who
have stop stop watches okay now I'm
going to do this a few times right each
pair I'm gonna get you to do it once
okay so hands up pairs where are you
okay so we just go left left to right
for you guys anyway okay now what you're
gonna do you both need to start your
stop watches when I release okay both of
you start when I throw the ball okay but
the two of you the reason why you're
paired up is because you're gonna do
you're going to stop at different times
okay I want the first person whoever it
is
okay I want you to stop your timer when
the ball gets to the top where it where
it stops as it were okay I want you to
stop at that time the second person is
going to stop when I catch it assuming I
do okay
so you both stay at the same time I'm
gonna do this lots of different ways and
then you're going to stop it at the top
and then when I catch it okay so first
time actually we'll get two pairs to do
each one cuz I'm going to throw it
different heights okay so that we get
some verification all right so we've got
two pairs here right so you guys ready
okay so you guys cool off and you wait
for the next one right so I'll count you
in
okay three two one all right did you get
your x I can't hold on to them for a
second who's our next pair of pairs
heads up
yeah okay I'll try it throw it up a bit
further this time
all right so you're gonna have to watch
this one you can try and pair to get
this one okay so as you try and follow
the ball I can find all right I'm gonna
try and throw it up far enough so watch
carefully all right you ready catch it
three two one and then we'll do three
two one okay okay one last time we have
a pair of pants to do it yeah okay this
is gonna be bad are you ready last time
better than any guys ready are you gonna
do this well you can the more we have
the better consistent okay so you ready
I'll catch you three two one okay
a little bit but did you get it do I
need to do it again you didn't stop it
okay let's try again this time going to
throw it as high as I can basically and
still go last time I count you in three
two one let's just do a test can you um
if I if I throw it up can you can you
pan fast enough in order to catch it
I'll catch it okay
ready 3 2 did you go down it's a video
game control man it's not inverted or
anything up is up down let's try to get
you ready 3 2 1
did you catch it mostly okay it's gonna
be a great bloop is real